jérôme blanchet gravel journaliste
essayiste jérôme blanchet gravel merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur air
france alors françois legault le premier
ministre du québec parle d'une situation
critique critique à quel point on ne
sait pas exactement c'est un peu
scepticisme d'ailleurs la population
malgré l'apparence de consensus je vous
dirais que quand même une certaine
satisfaction qui commencent à émerger
donc jusqu'à quel point ces justifie on
ne sait pas exactement parce que de
toute façon vous le savez n'est pas
vraiment de consensus scientifique sur
les mesures à adopter du moins il y en a
parmi le gouvernement le gouvernement
évidemment des mesures très nette
l'autre est clair ceci dit jusqu'à quel
point c'est pas moi qui pourrait vous
répondre exactement sur cette question
là tout le monde un peu son avis sur la
question la dangerosité du virus
actuellement en tout cas fermeture des
restaurants des bars des casinos des
théâtres des bibliothèques pas de
réception à domicile et le gouvernement
qui demande à ses concitoyens de ne pas
se déplacer d'une région à l'autre
ça ressemble quand même un confinement
partiel oui tout à fait c'est ccc un
confinement mais on veut pas
nécessairement l'avouer mais on en
entendra un emploi par exemple le mot
confinement avaient confinement enfin je
me rappelle avoir attendu mais on y est
c'est à peu près la même chose le
premier ministre le bo a même évoqué la
possibilité d'akkas pectives d'une
quatrième vague donc qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est que on en a un pour
longtemps cette crise la durée et nous
on se prépare à ce que la crise dure
très longtemps donc quand je parle
d'insatisfaction glaçante
évidemment les gestes de plus en plus
inquiets par rapport aux dommages
collatéraux un dommages collatéraux
économique de match
latéraux et psychologique lexicologue
vous diront peut-être que l'état général
la population sur le plan de la santé
mentale c'est pas top niveau comme vous
pourriez en france c'est ce qui est
déplorable une certaine façon c'est qu'à
mon avis le gouvernement legault a
adopté la philosophie du risque zéro
donc on est un peu dans une utopie
sanitaires c'est à dire vrai sport oui
parce qu'en fait finalement la situation
dans les hôpitaux par exemple est-ce
qu'ils sont saturés aujourd'hui
apparemment non les habitants sont pas
encore saturés c'est à dire qu'il s'agit
encore ce que je comprends et plusieurs
interprétations
on n'est pas encore tout à fait dans la
deuxième vague fins et on essaie de la
penne certains disent qu'on l'a on est
on est dedans j'ai parlé à des médecins
voient comme journaliste en carrière qui
me disait que on n'était pas tout à fait
encore dans la deuxième vague
donc comme je vous dis le consensus
scientifique
il y en a pas exactement vous le savez
enfants vous avez eu des débats aussi
les médecins sont consensuelles donc
est-ce qu'on est là qu'on voyait arriver
à cette deuxième vague là parce que je
veux lâchement laissé aller bas dans les
restos rappelé chez les jeunes en
particulier que se sentent moins
vulnérable mais c'est pas moi qui va
vous parler de qui va vous dire son
abandon matic qu' on est absolument la
deuxième les folles en tout cas montréal
et québec passe au plus haut niveau d'
alerte pendant 28 jours
est ce qu'il ya des risques ce que cela
s'étende à d'autres provinces selon vous
s'il faut savoir au canada c'est que la
santé c'est un domaine de compétence
provinciale donc chaque commerçant son
foc appareils de mesure donc c'est paul
dans la réaction est pas uniforme au
canada donc est-ce que c'est l'airé
contagion peut s'étendre aux autres
provinces c'est dur à dire
je pense que toutes les provinces si
jamais d'ailleurs les voyages entre les
provinces sont fortement déconseillés
l'autre
donc ce sera à voir l'ontario ce que par
également 12ème la presse canadienne la
plus populeuse cap a elle aussi à faire
face à une deuxième vague apparemment
plus monstrueuse que la première
donc tout ça reste à voir d'un dès les
prochains jours alors les milieux de la
restauration ou encore les milieux
culturels estime qu'il sortait lentement
la tête de l'eau les conséquences
économiques sûr qu'elles vont quelque
est est-ce qu'elles vont être après ces
nouvelles mesures de restriction
bonne question le jeu tactilo lui je
vous parle d'utopie sanitaire justin
trudeau lui semble plutôt dans les deux
filles économique il multiplie les aides
financières aux particuliers aux
établissements privés au commerce
quel sera l'état du canada
économiquement parlant à la crise c'est
une bonne question
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on le voit c'est
tangible on voit de plus en plus de
commerces fermés on le voyait des
panneaux qik est donc dans la rue c'est
quelque chose de tangible elie centre
ville sont désertées les gens en font du
télétravail
donc le centre-ville de montréal par
exemple ça va extrêmement mal ça va
extrêmement le centre-ville de montréal
c'est une catastrophe donc jusqu'à quel
point les gouvernements vont pouvoir
imposer ce genre de mesures là
évidemment qui dit impact économique des
impacts psychologiques comme juste au
début c'est ça vaut toujours ensemble
merci beaucoup jérôme blanchet gravel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions de nous
avoir éclairé sur la situation à
montréal et au québec je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et essayiste